multiply 1 and 3/4 times 7 and 1/5
simplify your answer and write it as a
mixed fraction so the first thing we
want to do is rewrite each of these
mixed numbers as improper fractions it's
very difficult or at least it's not easy
for me to directly multiply mixed
numbers one can do it but it's it's much
easier if you just make them improper
fractions so let's convert each of them
so one in 3/4 1 and 3/4 is equal to it's
still going to be over 4 so you're still
going to have the same denominator but
your numerator as an improper fraction
is going to be 4 times 1 plus 3/4 times
1 plus 3 and the reason why this makes
sense is 1 is 4/4 or 1 is 4 times 1/4
right 1 is the same thing as 4/4 and
then you have three more fourths so 4/4
plus 3/4 will give you 7/4 will give you
7/4 so that's the same thing as 1 and
3/4 now let's do 7 and 1/5 7 and 1/5 7
and 1/5 same exact process you're still
going to have we're going to still be
talking in terms of fifths that's going
to be the denominator and you take 5
times 7 because think about it 7 is the
same thing as 35 fifths so you take 5
times 7 so it's 5 times 7 Plus this
numerator right here so 7 is 35 fifths
then you have one more fifth so you're
going to have 35 plus one which is equal
to 36 36 fifths so this product is the
exact same thing as taking the product
of 7 over 4 times 36 over 5 times 36
over 5 and we could multiply it out
right now take the 7 times 36 is our new
numerator 4 times 5 is our new
denominator but that'll give us a large
numbers I can't multiply 7 and 36 in my
head or I can't do it too easily so
let's see if we can simplify this first
so our both our numerator and our
denominator have numbers that are
divisible by 4 so let's divide both the
numerator and the denominator
meter by four so the numerator we can
divide the 36 by four we can divide the
36 by four and get nine and if you
divide something in the numerator by
four you have to divide something in the
denominator by 4 and this before is the
obvious guy so 4 divided by 4 is 1 so
now this becomes 7 times 9 and what's 7
times 9 63 over 1 times 5 over 5 so now
we have our answer as an improper
fraction but they want it as a mixed
number or as a mixed fraction so what
are 63 fifths so to figure that out to
figure that out let me pick a nice color
here we take 5 into 63 5 goes into 6 one
time one times five is five
you subtract 6 minus one is sorry 6
minus 5 is 1 bring down the 3 five goes
into 13 two times and you could have
immediately said five goes into 63 12
times but this way it's it's at least it
to me it's a little bit more obvious and
then 2 times 5 is 12 is 12 and then we
have sorry 2 times 5 is 10 my 2 times 5
is 10 it tells you not to switch gears
in the middle of a math problem 2 times
5 is 10 and then you subtract and you
have a remainder of 3 you have a
remainder of 3 so 63 fifths is the same
thing as 12 as 12 holes and 3 leftover
or 3/5 or 3/5 leftover and if you wanted
to go back from this to that just think
12 is the same thing as 60 fifths or 60
over 560 over 5 plus 3 over 5 is 63 over
5 so these two things are the same thing
these two things are equivalent this is
as an improper fraction this is as a
mixed number or a mixed fraction but
this is our answer right there 12 and
3/5